now we can't help but wonder if you're
going to be the one to save the day
again in descendants three without hades
ember will you be able to save our dawn
from the unfathomable dark force if that
ember really has been destroyed what
will you do with all your friends turn
to stone will you have to enlist help
from an unlikely hero we happen to have
a theory about that
keep watching to the end to discover a
crazy way now might be able to use the
power of the Ember even after it gets
destroyed were you so arrogant to think
if you wrong us we shall not seek
revenge in the official trailer for
descendants three mouths voiceover tells
us that Hades ember is crucial in
defeating evil she says the only thing
more powerful than the curse of the
scepter is Hades ember in case we were
in any doubt now makes it crystal clear
when she then says unless I get that
ember it's game over it totally looks
like it's game over when Celia destroys
the Ember by throwing it into the well
if the ember is gone
how will now say today without it we can
envision a few possible alternatives for
defeating evil firstly there are the
Pirates sure uma is presented as wanting
revenge on Mount both also seem very
strong hints at uma Harry hook and Gil
are going to join the V Ches and help
them we see them fighting against the
armored soldiers with mal and the gang
since I've been living on the Isle of
the Lost
they might have some inside information
on how to stop the sleeping spell we
here uma herself put forward her gang as
the solution to the problem when she
says moon was the only one holding the
Ember when Mao says to her I need that
to break a spell even if they no longer
have the blue stone the Pirates could be
the key to saving auradon but they might
not be doing it out of the goodness of
their hearts they might have to cut a
deal with Mao their reward could be
permanent residents in auradon if you
think it's too unlikely that the pirates
could help save the day without the
Ember then what about an a K instead we
also think Jane could be the one that
helps now defeat evil
you see when those voices telling us
about the importance of the ember we
aren't looking at her on screen we're
actually shown Jane going underwater
she's fully clothed
has her eyes wide open under the surface
of the enchanted lake could she be
looking for the Ember in there let's
back up and explain this theory the well
does Celia throws the Ember into might
be connected to the lake where else with
the water at the bottom of the well come
from if that is the case then it makes
total sense that the ember isn't
actually destroyed when it's thrown down
the well it might be lost within the
depths of the lake jane clearly manages
to avoid the sleeping spell she might
also manage to avoid being turned to
stone with the rest of the vks and then
turned to stone mouths going to need an
ally perhaps Jane is the one who's going
to step up to the plate we need to back
up even further for our next theory sure
we see Celia throw the ember into the
well but that might not be the real
story we cut to a shot of Celia laughing
holding her cards that reminds us that
dr. facile ears daughter is a trickster
in her meet Celia trailer she explains
that she's all about the hustle she
tricks people to believe her lies hero
it's me a tall handsome stranger I
already have so it's possible that Celia
is trying to trick now into believing
that she destroyed the ember but it
could be a fake ember she used to
distract her if that's the case then
Celia might secretly still have the real
thing so there'd be a chance that it
could be found and used to reverse the
sleeping spell the next possibility uses
proof from the previous two movies that
now doesn't need an ember to help her
defeat evil in the first film now uses
the power of friendship to defeat her
mother when Maleficent turns into a
dragon at Ben's coronation now chance
[Music]
mouths words were so powerful they
reduced Maleficent to a tiny lizard but
with the rest of mouths closest friends
turned to stone in d3 she might find it
difficult to round up so many hearts to
stand as one this time around that's why
a Mau might use the same trick she used
in descendants - to defeat the evil
force once and for all
Mau turns into a dragon to defeat uma
indeed - and in the trailer for d3 we
see mouths transformation into a dragon
once again she didn't need Hades ember
in order to make that change before so
she could well use her dragon powers to
defeat the perpetrator of evil which
sure looks like Audrey
finally we're taking a clue from the
change in mouths hair colour as to how
the embers power might live on even if
it gets destroyed maou signature purple
locks turned blue in this movie and we
all know who else has blue hair Hades
his hair even glows brighter blue when
he uses the embers power perhaps when
mal thought Hades was draining her power
with the Ember he was actually giving
her new power the power of the Ember
that's why her hair is blue and that's
how she can still save the day so that's
a wrap on what destroying the Ember
could mean in descendants 3 who do you
think help smell defeat evil let us know
in the comments give this video a big
thumbs up if you're excited for d3 and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]